my name is elvis utiano i live in
nairobi that's in kenya
and i'm a country musician way down in
[Music]
the state of georgia
[Music]
down the road
[Music]
down the road
[Music]
[Music]
country music was my first love
my parents i think looking back at it
were
very unique in a way because they loved
country music they had all the records
and i listened to all the beautiful
music that was there
that kind of like shaped up the person
that i was to become later in my life
we
identify quite a lot with country music
because of the message that is in it
family
love heartbreak
from the coal mines of kentucky
to the
california sun
i draw a lot of inspirations from
different singers and different
songwriters god brooks charlie pride
alan jackson john williams george
straits brooks and dunn the list is
endless the struggles they experience
are
really universal
[Music]
one more time
every time i've gone on stage i have to
make sure
my audience are with me and they get my
message and usually what i want them to
feel is the raw
emotions
of a song
say this talk with me
as i walk the streets
of my mane
i'm just like a vessel
but through me
they can feel
the emotions
and it has to be real it has to come
from your heart
[Music]
thank you thank you so much